la guerre est une somme de bataille de
phases elle n'est pas linéaire celle-ci
peut se décomposer en quatre phases
l'invasion ratée la nouvelle stratégie
russe la contre-offensive ukrainienne
ukrainienne pardon l'hiver et la
campagne aérienne la première phase
c'est celle de l'invasion manquée elle
débute le 24 février et va durer 45
jours jusqu'à l'ami avril le temps que
Poutine réalise que c'est généreux lui
mentent une offensive russe repoussée
par les Ukrainiens qui s'est terminé par
un désastre stratégique et militaire
pour la Russie les explications de ce
désastre sont multiples mais c'est
d'abord la conséquence d'une analyse
totalement
erronée des Russes sur trois points la
première c'est l'existence d'une nation
ukrainienne le deuxième c'est la
surestimation de la puissance de l'armée
russe et le troisième c'est la
sous-estimation de la puissance de
l'armée ukrainienne les Russes pensaient
que la résistance ukrainienne serait
minime et que Kiev est le dombage
tomberait aussi facilement que la Crimée
en 2014 une faute majeure de la part de
Poutine et de ses services de
renseignement dont d'ailleurs il mangera
très rapidement la plupart des chefs ce
qu'il continue à faire régulièrement
vis-à-vis de ces généra
par exemple c'est ainsi que la fine
fleur de l'armée russe qui sont les
forces parachutistes qui sont totalement
indépendantes et super équipées et bien
se sont fait décimer lorsqu'elles ont
tenté fait une tentative de débarquement
aéroportée sur les repères d'ostenmel
lors de la prise de Kiev tout au début
de la guerre
dans cette phase les Russes vont
conquérir tout de même sans pratiquement
aucun combat une grande partie du
territoire de l'Ukraine dont la ville et
la région de Kerson et la centrale
nucléaire de sapory Jack défaille
laconique depuis le début de la guerre
cette face cette deuxième phase se
termine le 18 avril avec une humiliation
majeure pour Russie pour la Russie la
marine ukrainienne qui n'a pas de bateau
zéro bateau ils avaient une frégate
qu'ils ont s'aborder le 3 mars elle
arrive à couler le plus puissant navire
de la flotte le croiseur moxva le plus
puissant bateau le bateau amiral de la
faute de la flotte noire de la flotte
russe en mer Noire pendant une
humiliation majeure pour les Russes
qu'ils essaieront de cacher le plus
longtemps possible les Ukrainiens ont
gagné la première phase de la guerre
sans aucune ambiguïté comment selon la
deuxième phase c'est celle de la
nouvelle stratégie russe il s'agit de
concentrer pour la Russie les efforts
sur le dombases d'abord et sur le
contrôle de la mer Noire ensuite cette
phase va durer quatre mois jusqu'au mois
d'août les Russes vont progresser dans
le Dombas au prix de lourdes pertes à la
mi-juillet ils vont avoir pris le
contrôle de la totalité de l'aublage de
l'ougance et 80% de celui de Donetsk les
Russes contrôlent à présent une partie
importante de l'Ukraine plus les 27000
km² de la Crimée mais ils sont toujours
confrontés au même problème pas assez
d'hommes toujours pas assez d'hommes et
un commandement défaillant ils vont
néanmoins gagner cette deuxième phase de
la guerre avec deux victoires
symboliques la conquête de la totalité
de l'aublasque de l'audience que je le
dis et surtout la victoire la prise de
la ville martyre de Mario Paul dont tout
le monde a suivi les différents épisodes
par contre ils vont se montrer incapable
de poster l'offensive jusqu'à au dessin
c'est un point important au dessin ne
tombera pas donc évidemment Poutine va
être obligé de revoir ses objectifs à la
baisse d'ailleurs dans cette guerre et
deux chefs de guerre que sont élastiques
et Poutine passe leur temps à revoir
leurs objectifs de guerre ça je pense
que c'est un élément important pour
comprendre des décrypter cette guerre
pour la Russie c'est toujours le même
problème pas assez d'hommes pour un
front des 1000 km du côté ukrainien la
mobilisation est décédée le premier jour
elle porte ses fruits des dizaines de
milliers de combattants armés par les
Occidentaux ont renforcé les rangs de
l'armée régulière la nation ukrainienne
est en arme elle est galvanisée par un
chef exceptionnel Vladimir et l'inscris
la troisième phase est celle de la
contrefensive ukrainienne cette phase ne
sera visible qu'au mois d'août avec les
mouvements de troupe mais en réalité
elle a commencé dès le mois de juin
grâce à la livraison de canons comme le
canon César mais surtout grâce au High
mars
américain britannique et allemand ce
sont des armes qui frappent loin et fort
avec une très grande précision grâce au
guidage satellite des obus et au
renseignement US bien évidemment chaque
roquette tirée est un coût au but
pendant des semaines les Ukrainiens vont
s'empolier à détruire le deuxième
échelon russe c'est-à-dire la logistique
des pots de carburant les dépôts de
munitions en outre les Ukrainiens vont
concevoir une opération de déception
remarquable ils vont faire croire au
Russe qu'ils vont attaquer à Kerson au
sud alors qu'il lance la contrefensive
au nord de la région de kerkiv n'ayant
pas assez d'hommes les Russes n'ont pas
d'autres solutions que le soucouper soit
la main droite ou la main gauche et
choisiront de sauver Kerson et cela va
entraîner une débâcle dans le Nord le 21
septembre Poutine déclare la
mobilisation partielle et Alex les
territoires occupés un nouveau tournant
dans cette guerre la troisième phase la
phase de la contrepensive et gagner par
les Ukrainiens nous sommes actuellement
dans la quatrième phase la quatrième
phase a commencé le 8 octobre alors vous
souvenez le 8 octobre c'est une date
importante c'est la de l'attentat contre
le pont de kirsch qui relie la Crimée à
la Russie attentat qui n'a toujours pas
été revendiqué par définition puisqu'il
est clandestins donc le définition de la
progressivité c'est qu'on sait pas qui
c'est bon on a quand même une petite
idée
une humiliation pour Poutine cette
affaire du pont de guerre qui va
d'ailleurs en profiter pour nommer je
pense qu'il avait il avait déjà calcu
avant un nouveau général à la tête des
opérations il s'appelle sorovikin et sur
revikine n'est pas un aviateur mais il a
commandé les forces russes en Syrie dans
lequel il est largement utilisé la
version bombardement et surtout il a
également commandé les forces
aérospatiale russe et les forces
aérospatiales russes c'est aussi l'armée
des Russes donc pour la première fois on
a un général terrien à la tête de
l'opération qui connaît l'aviation et la
puissance aérienne à partir de sa
nomination la guerre va changer de
nature
cette phase comporte également le
retrait finalement inattendu des troupes
russes de Kerson qui se replient pour la
première fois en bonne ordre et qui va
ainsi vont éviter un encerclement et une
défaite probablement inévitable et c'est
à ce moment-là que sur Viking va décider
de lancer la première campagne aérienne
rue russe vraiment efficace des raids
incessantes de drone iraniens shell 136
vous on les voit bien c'est drone je
pourrais en reparler mais surtout des
raids des bombes des stratégiques qui
décollent de base russe située à moins
de 40 minutes de vol de la frontière
tout à l'heure je vous montrais une
photo de Tupolev 160 un tupolet 160 ça
peut emporter et tirer 12000 sites de
croisière qui font 2500 km de portée et
qui ont une charge militaire de 400 kg
c'est bombardiers ne franchissent même
pas la frontière ils sont donc
totalement invulnérables
la seule solution pour les Ukrainiens
est alors d'intercepter ses missiles ce
qui est possible mais évidemment il
manque de système de défense antiériens
c'est ce qui m'ont réclamer à partir de
à partir de cette date là les cibles
sont d'abord des cibles
d'infrastructures civiles mais aussi des
cibles plus militaires comme les usines
d'armement et les sites militaires
je précise parce que je l'ai rajouté
entre temps donc j'ai parlé de les
Russes les Ukrainiens depuis dimanche et
c'est un événement important de cette
guerre ont décidé de frapper ces bases
aériennes avec des drones de
renseignements de la guerre froide
bricoler qui sont transformés en missile
de croisière et ça c'est un nouveau
tournant dans la guerre et on en parlera
peut-être un peu plus tard
l'objectif de la campagne aérienne il
est double premièrement c'est faire
souffrir la population alors que l'hiver
arrive mais aussi paralyser l'économie
ukrainienne afin de freiner l'effort de
guerre
dans le même temps les Russes prennent
des positions défensives pour protéger
la Crimée cela arrive gauche du Nièvre
le Nièvre un fleuve puissant et large
qui constitue une ligne naturelle de
séparation difficilement franchissable
c'est là où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
c'est la petite raspoutite ça la petite
période des pluies qui va précéder les
chutes de neige et l'arrivée et
l'arrivée des sols gelés la question et
est-ce que c'est cette météo va
permettre aux Ukrainiens de reprendre
l'offensive ou aux Russes de reprendre
du terrain sur les Ukrainiens la nous
allons le savoir bientôt par contre ce
qu'on sait c'est que la campagne
aérienne va se poser aussi longtemps que
la Russie aura des missiles pour le
moment malgré les prévisions cela ne
semble pas poser de problème je rappelle
que l'été dernier Poutine a fait voter
des unocase qui fait passer l'économie
russe en économie de guerre c'est la
priorité aux usines d'armement Russie en
ce moment